how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to the MCU today we have some
really big news about the 4th Thor film
Thor love and thunder and the guardians
of the galaxy the guardians of the
galaxy are officially confirmed to be
making an appearance in Thor at love and
thunder and more than just dropping Thor
off on wherever he's going in his quest
in the new movie they will actually have
quite a bit of airtime in the movie and
will contribute to the story so you know
what that means it's looking like Thor
and star-lord are going to have to fight
over who's captain of the ship a little
bit longer well are you making your
voice deeper no you are you're imitating
the god man this is my voice so we'll
talk about the Guardians in Thor love
and thunder talk about Vin Diesel
mentioning alpha Groot and the future of
Groot in the MCU and talk about how Adam
warlock and the Silver Surfer are the
most likely reasons for the Guardians to
team up with Thor and for love and
thunder if you are new to the channel be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 so
originally the guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 film was supposed to come out
before Thor love and thunder according
to comicbook.com
Thor was set to appear with the
guardians in guardians vol 3 so Thor and
the guardians were destined to be
together in the MCU no matter what
however with the firing and rehiring of
James Gunn but him having to direct
Suicide Squad before he can do anything
with guardians of the galaxy vol 3 it
got pushed back and now of course as we
know we are getting Thor love and
thunder before guardians 3 however the
guardians are tagging along
so this confirmation that the guardians
are going to be appearing in Thor at
love and thunder comes from Vin Diesel
himself of course he plays the voice of
Groot in guardians of the galaxy and in
a recent interview for his upcoming
movie bloodshot he talked about the
guardians of the galaxy and how it's
confirmed that they're going to be in
Thor at love and thunder Thor will also
the director talk to me about how Thor
will incorporate some of the guard
the galaxy which would be very
interesting nobody knows but maybe I
shouldn't have said anything
so according to Vin Diesel one the
Suicide Squad might be pretty good and
two it is confirmed that some of the
guardians will appear in Thor eleven
thunder and he said that Taika Waititi
the director of thor ragnarok and the
upcoming thor four confirmed that to him
himself now this doesn't come as that
big of a surprise after all this was set
up at the end of Avengers in game where
Thor left with the Guardians on their
ship not sure the first time the
thousand years I have no path I do have
a ride though but Vin Diesel may have
revealed a little bit about what to
expect from the Guardians and Thor love
and thunder a little bit later on in the
interview I only have two words about
that character and it is alpha group so
Vin Diesel mentions alpha Groot now in
the comics there is no character
classified as alpha group so this could
mean one of two things one is that he
could become a version of King Groot
King Groot is an alternate version of
grouped who never met Rocket Raccoon
never met or joined the guardians of the
galaxy but actually went on to become a
galactic warlord instead he basically
looks like group from the first
guardians of the galaxy film if he
evolved one route it's been traveling
recently as Rockets personal house
plants slash muscle if he seems a little
bit familiar it's also because he
appears in Marvel's contest of Champions
so he could go on to become King Groot
in the MCU or he could go on to become
the leader of his species the flora
Colossus we know that guardians three is
going to explore the history and origin
of Rocket Raccoon James Gunn has
confirmed this himself so it would make
sense that they would explore groots
origin as well but think back to
Avengers end game where they mentioned
that Thor actually speaks Groot and
Groot and Thor do have a pretty tight
relationship after all groots arm is the
handle for Stormbreaker so maybe one of
the places that Thor and the guardians
of the galaxy go to is groots homeworld
and there we may get to see alpha Groot
but why else would the guardians of the
galaxy be teaming up with Thor in a
movie that is specifically about Thor
and Jane Foster
I mean Thor as well well there are
really two main most likely options one
is Adam warlock and two is the Silver
Surfer both options work perfectly and
the stories that they could go down make
perfect sense for starters it is
official that Christian Bale has been
cast for Thor love and thunder and he
will be playing the villain this was
confirmed by Tessa Thompson who plays
Val Christian Bale's character that he's
going to be playing in Thor love and
thunder is said to be other worldly and
alien like that could definitely be Adam
warlock or the Silver Surfer and there's
a big presidents for both at the end of
guardians volume 2 Adam warlock was set
up the high sovereign introduced his
cocoon and Aisha explained that his sole
purpose was to destroy the guardians of
the galaxy beautiful capable of
destroying the guardians of the galaxy
I think I shall call him
Madame so Adam warlock was supposed to
be at least for the most part of villain
of guardians of the galaxy vol 3 now
ultimately in the comics he starts off
as a villain but becomes good and since
we know that guardians of the galaxy vol
3 is going to be picking up right after
the events of Avengers endgame where
Thor leaves with the guardians Adam
warlock should exist and be out of his
cocoon somewhere in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
because guardians of the galaxy vol 2
presumably ended not too long before
Avengers infinity war started the
guardians found four and then at the end
of Infinity Ward vanos snapped
then of course an endgame we went five
years forward into the future and at the
end of in game when Thor and the
Guardians lived together that is
presumably between five and seven years
after the events of guardians vol 2 five
to seven years is definitely enough time
for Adam warlock to fully form so in
theory but also logically Adam warlock
should be out there somewhere searching
for the Guardians because that is his
sole purpose he was created for and Adam
warlock is one of the most powerful
characters ever created by Marvel and
will definitely be one of the most
powerful characters in the MCU
and if we consider this that means that
the guardians really can't take him on
by themselves especially after star-lord
lost his celestial light powers and
Guardians too however Thor most likely
can yes he's still technically brothe or
after Avengers in game but he still
managed to put up a heck of a fight
against Thanos an in-game perhaps
running into Adam warlock is what he
needs to kick his butt into shape and
based off of what we know about
guardians volume three Adam warlock
isn't going to be the primary main
villain in fact we have every reason to
believe that Adam warlock will
eventually be good the main villain of
the film is most likely going to be the
High Evolutionary and Thor is still most
likely to appear in the next guardians
film that was the plane before guardians
3 got moved back and it still sounds
like James Gunn hasn't really changed
much of the script because he's had it
written for quite some time now and that
script involved Thor so in a way the
story will start in Thor love and
thunder but will end in guardians vol 3
and not to mention the first mention of
the High Evolutionary was in the Mighty
Thor at number 133 and the first full
appearance was in the Mighty Thor number
134 in November of 1966 so the story and
the connection seems to line up
place so Thor and the Guardians will
most likely run into Adam warlock and
Thor love and thunder and then take on
the High Evolutionary and guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 but there is also one
other character that makes a lot of
sense story wise for the Guardians and
Thor to run into and that is the Silver
Surfer the Eternals will hit the big
screen soon and it's widely speculated
that they could be introducing and
hinting at Galactus Galactus is set to
be the next big bad of the MCU and if
Galactus is coming that means one of his
Herald is coming first and of course the
most famous Herald is the Silver Surfer
Earth has drawn a lot of attention it
was ground zero for the snap a cosmic
energy burst that the universe has never
seen before and the purpose of the
Silver Surfer is to seek out planets and
energy that Galactus can consume and it
would just make sense that he would
eventually run into earth and perhaps on
his way to earth he runs into a ship and
on that ship are the Guardians and Thor
now Thor is kind of an ancient being
he's over 1500 years old he probably
knows who Galactus is and he definitely
knows about the heralds if he knows who
he is because we know that Thor has to
make it back to earth for whatever
reason Jane Foster is on earth and we
know that she's going to become Thor and
wield Mjolnir in love and thunder so
perhaps the Silver Surfer is why he
returns the guardians and Thor will be
in space somewhere they could run into
him after discovering who he is and what
he plans to do Thor could simply use
Stormbreaker to summon the Bifrost to go
back to earth and this is where Thor and
the guardians could split up this would
also provide a reason for why Jane is
actually going to become Thor in the
movie Thor is a God and quite possibly
the strongest character that currently
exists in the MCU but when the Silver
Surfer The Herald of Galactus comes he
will have the power cosmic a power
gifted to him from Galactus himself and
a power that Thor probably won't be able
to handle on his own but perhaps with
the help of Jane Foster with another
mighty Mjolnir they might just stand a
chance so story wise the Silver Surfer
makes a lot of sense and after all
Christian Bale is speculated to be
playing the Silver Surfer but let me
know what do you think about this what
do you think is going to bring the
Guardians and Thor together in Thor love
and thunder and then once again in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 drop all
your thoughts and theories in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay
up-to-date on all things relating to the
MC
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm
picking the winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers follow me on
Twitter and Instagram for live MCU
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof